qué punto están ahora mismo las
posiciones de las dos partes Será
posible retomar el diodo el diálogo a
corto plazo
Buenas noches Rodrigo agradecerte por la
invitación si justamente hoy día el
gobierno hace minutos nada más instó a
que este viernes cuatro de este mes se
sientan las mesas técnicas al dialogar
justamente para ver cuándo se va a
realizar el censo 2023 lo que sí el
gobierno está ignorando justamente a
raíz de las imágenes que están viendo en
pantalla ayer se gestó prácticamente por
más de 12 horas
mucha violencia alrededor de Santa Cruz
movimientos pagados personas realmente
agrupadas con mucha violencia queriendo
entrar a la ciudad justamente a atentar
contra las personas que viven en Santa
Cruz y son personas que están avaladas
por el gobierno personas que van de la
mano de la policía y que justamente han
cercado Santa Cruz no permiten que pasen
alimentos que pase gasolina entonces
están prácticamente
atentando contra todas las ciudadanía y
justamente a raíz de este de esta
violencia que se dio el comité
interinstitucional le pidió al gobierno
que liberen a las personas definidas que
abroguen el decreto que justamente avala
que el censo se haga el 2024 cuando se
podría hacer el 2023 y ciertas otras
condiciones para dialogar y no así
directamente pasar a la mesa técnica que
es lo que ellos quieren no y por qué
cree usted que el gobierno planea
retrasar este censo hasta 2024 y no a
2023 como piden los manifestantes
es gracioso es gracioso y le digo por
qué Porque justamente todo este año
ministros el mismo director del
Instituto Nacional de estadística
garantizaron que sí va a ser este este
este 18 de noviembre el censo en todo el
país dijeron que tenían ya los créditos
que los dio el banco interamericano de
desarrollo y con plata y estaba todo
listo financieramente y
organizacionalmente pero por un motivo y
que es sencillo son cálculos políticos
decidieron retrasarlo Qué es lo que
ocurre el censo nos va a permitir
justamente limpiar nuestro paro para un
electoral saber cuántos somos dónde
estamos y Qué necesitamos y para ahí nos
va a poder permitir justamente
planificarnos Y estos resultados del
censo que es que el gobierno los quiere
atrasar muchísimo si si esto se atrasan
no van a poder validar la nueva
redistribución de los recursos y también
de los escaños parlamentarios entonces
Esto va a afectar las elecciones
nacionales del 2025 misma situación que
no beneficiaría por supuesto al gobierno
porque donde más se benefician son todos
los departamentos que van a tener
mayores recursos en Bolivia el gobierno
maneja el 80% del presupuesto general
sobre el 20% se reparten en Por así
decirlo en los distintos niveles del
Estado Entonces el gobierno no se va a
ver beneficiado porque realmente van a
salir a luz muchísimas cosas que han
venido ocultando todo este tiempo no